and on the mound for the blue jays
staring in it's the big left-hander
hyunjin ryu 26th start of the season and
he ranks among the best in the american
league in several categories one and two
the count on a mount castle
and a swing into this got him with a
changeup off the outside corner well he
has one of the best changeups in all of
baseball but he has to offset that with
enough fastball command strikeouts that
time took the took a little bit more off
of it
that's great arm speed really fooling
that batter
another 2-2
line down to third and kevin smith is up
to the task two down
adam played just right didn't they hayes
has had some big hits against the blue
jays this season he's hit the ball hard
against the jays a little unlucky
hitting right there as he hits it right
at smith and another
and he got him
big strikeout of orios and the orioles
will leave a couple of men on at the top
of the first and they'll take their
swings off 26 year old keegan aiken
from alba michigan former second round
pick by the orioles back in 2016.
and he gets him
change up and a good one outstanding
that's exactly what he'll need to do
tonight you see severino set up exactly
where it's delivered you can't do it any
better than that had to throw 28 pitches
in the first inning walked a couple he
has thrown 16 here in the second even
though he's retired the first two
batters facing the third so again the
pitch count kind of climbing onto ryu in
the early going got it
swinging a miss at a fastball three up
three down go the orioles in the top of
the second yeah coming right back in
again yes well done threw it by him
strike three so a couple of base runners
but keegan aiken retires the last two
is there actually a man down in the
bullpen right now now janssen and his
return to the roster hits it out
welcome back danny jackson
before he got injured for the second
time with the hamstrings
his bat was a little bit better he had a
three-game hit streak going
so you know it was killing him that he
was feeling a little bit better pulling
that hamstring and then having to wait
around for about six weeks as he gets to
wear the jacket for the first time
[Applause]
stay right there danny that was a pretty
swing on that fastball
two two on the way
and he got him looking
good strikeout for hernan hernandez down
aitkin
with bouchette still standing at second
base fastball in for strike two
eighth pitch of the at-bat and he gets
him
curiel went fishing on a pitch way
outside
back-to-back strikeouts after the
lead-off double there you go
looping fly ball right field hayes
coming hard and he dives and gets there
austin hayes flashing the speed
big play there to get aiken out of the
inning and austin hayes has been a
difference maker on defense
on the inside corner
severino didn't agree so they'd strike
out number four for ryu remember i was
telling you every pitch has a purpose
change up cutter
one on the outside corner
one clips that inside corner gets the
call from the home plate umpire starting
pitching in defense that's how you win
swing and a miss to get them
back-to-back strikeouts two down a
couple of fastballs up for strike one
and strike two then you go just a little
bit further up
maybe you can get mateo to chase and he
does
got it what a curveball ryu strikes out
the side he is getting better and better
as the game moves along five hitless
innings for ryu
one two on the way
and he got him
two down or keegan aiken has trusted his
fastball in his last three starts i
don't know if he's throwing it as a
higher percentage this start as he did
his last one last one was 65 percent
this one's probably about in line with
his 57-58 percent but elevated just
enough right by the back of george
franklin you got to be careful with uh
mullins because
he can hit a breaking ball this one is
popped up ryu goes back and makes the
catch
and a hint of a smile for just a moment
after that play don't want to break the
concentration watch it ball goes up he
looks there's the shortstop i better go
over there and make the catch
and he hauls it in you don't see too
many pop-ups back to the mound
right field there's the first base hit
of the game for the orioles
fielded by hernandez
here comes the throw and he does get in
with a double
so ryan castle delivers a two-out base
hit
and the orioles have the tying run in
scoring position he just kind of insides
out this ball this ball gets on his hand
but ryan mount castle so strong shoots
it right down the right field line one
strike pitch
up the middle and into center field
mount castle around third
heading to the plate and he's in the
orioles have tied it up
rbi base hit for austin hayes who moves
up to second base on the throw there it
is rbi base hit runners in scoring
position a struggle for the orioles to a
lot to that losing streak and that ball
just stayed down on the second baseman
marcus simmons he thought he was going
to come up but 107 off the bat there's
ryan mount castle scoring the worlds
have tied this thing up
an rbi single with two out by austin
hayes it started with two quick outs
it's turned into a long inning there's a
line drive base hit into left field this
will give the orioles the lead
marias delivers again hayes is home
here comes the second run and diving
head first
and safe
anthony santander
and the orioles go on top three to one
guerrero tonight fly ball to deep center
fly ball to deep left just missed on a
couple of occasions now he drives one to
right
and he didn't miss hair third home run
in the last two nights for vladimir
guerrero jr
he may be shushing but everybody else is
making noise in this ballpark there's
not a doubter in the park tonight
he's back
number 39 on the season
tayo with third one down
3-2 there's the frisbee and it's stroked
into center field rbi base hit for jones
the orioles at a run mateo scores
and it's four to two orioles
orioles getting it done tonight with
runners in scoring position
now three for seven on the night one for
two two stolen bases still running a
little bit got him and the orioles win
salsa strikes out dyson and the birds
put one in the win column and even up
this series at a game of peace